He needs to know the truth
Let's truth about wall about himself. No one knows no one but me
Hey, everybody. We finally got that movie size finale
So there's so much stuff to pick through just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet
There is a new round of that
Hbo now giveaway happening - all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber leave a comment on this video so r.i.p
The wall there was this really awesome
Shot when it was snowing in King's landing as Jamie was leaving you go from the really big wide shot which looks really beautiful you
Could tell they definitely spent a ton of extra money to show King's landing in its full glory
They could have searched these floor map, and you see snow falling all over it
And it's a great visual metaphor for what's coming winter is coming for all of Westeros
But I'll say right off the bat
This is probably one of the best episodes of the season if not the best just because of all the character moments
So some of the characters had their best scenes of the season in this episode particularly tyrion
Who's been a bit of a problem this season?
So let's just go through top 10 wtF this is gonna be a little bit longer because the episode was longer
But starting with number 10 jon's group rolls up to the dragon pit you get a little bit of a history lesson
And you start getting those really awesome reunions Podrick and tyrion
Brienne in the hound that was so great you see how much the hound has turned around as a character when he chuckles and implies
That he's not gonna try and get in Brienne's way as if he wouldn't have a chance against her
So it's a really nice way to show how all these different
Groups have put aside their differences in common cause for the army of the dead
But the even more beautiful thing about the dragon pit later is crazy a place as it is I've done a couple
History videos about it about how Maegor the cruel is the one that created it when he blew up the great set of the time
The way the Cersei is blown up the great sept and you get that daenerys speech about how she feels like it was the beginning
Of the end for their family you try to chain up this
wonderful thing and control it and we've actually heard on the show before about how the dragons would grow smaller and smaller and smaller the
Skull that jon snow picks up is the one that's supposed to be as big as a dog
That's one of the book quotes where they literally say the last dragons that were alive were no bigger than hounds
Because it was the finale most of this was all in service of paying stuff off
But there was a lot of foreshadowing for next season, so I'll try to work that in as I work through this list here
But the dragon pit was great. I loved how awful you're on as being even cersei speaks up for tyrion although
I think mostly to keep things moving along there was so much a family in the episode that at first second
I was like maybe cersei is standing up for tyrion because he's family, but I think in her case
It was just to move things along more
But number nine speaking of family the hound lets the mountain know how it's going to end for him
You've always known so I feel like this is them telling us that they're gonna do clegane Bowl before season 8 is done
so the hound
Wants Clegane Bowl just as badly as you do
But there's all kinds of questions about
How is the mountain Gonna get up North is the hound Gonna come back to King's landing after they fight the army of the dead?
Because I don't see the next time they're gonna be in a room together
Unless they come back or cersei comes up to the north
I was a little surprised that Cersei didn't make any jokes about Daenerys rolling up with two dragons instead of three dragons
But I think that was to make you know number eight
Revealing the wight to everyone hit a little bit more so she does finally react to something like holy crap like she actually believes it
In that moment whether she believed it or not before she's always one of those masters of not betraying her emotion
So when she does get really emotional you know shit is on
It was a bit of a comedy reveal too as the hound sort of tiptoeing around the box everything's dead silent
You're just waiting for the jump-scare
So he kicks it over it comes out and as he hacks it to pieces qyburn picks up that hand
I love the look on his face. He's not scared at all
He's just completely fascinated by it because he's fascinated in the secrets of death
That's the whole reason why he was kicked out of the citadel he opened the bodies of the living to learn about death as opposed
To the opposite where you opened the bodies of the dead to learn about life
So if there's anybody in King's landing that is excited about the army of the dead right now
It is qyburn like holy crap I can learn so much from this maybe you'll have some sort of solution to help out
Samwell, but Samwell is really the one with all the information from the citadel they've already explained
What Euron's up to how he's going to get the Golden company and bring them back?
I was surprised by how quickly they paid off that you're on story line
I would have thought they would have saved that for season eight some big reveal like oh you thought that we went back to pyke
Nope, we came back with 20,000 soldiers
Horses and elephants, just think of what those would look like in the army of the dead
But they hit a couple nice beats with the characters even brienne and Jaime get a brief moment
Which is probably the whole reason why they wanted her in King's landing so they could have that Jamie moment where she says fuck loyalty
They raked John over the coals about his loyalty this is Gonna get you killed
Ned stark was an honorable person look what happened to him
And I think that's more to provide a counterpoint for Cersei in the episode you know so number seven the Cersei tyrion scene
Fantastic probably Tyrians best scene this season is almost like they were saving all the good stuff for Tyrion for this moment when he was
With Cersei and they just unload on each other
But you actually learned that Cersei
Understands that he didn't kill Joffrey but still blames him for marcella and tommen and she traces it all back to his killing of Tywin
But you know then he also throws their mother in their face I killed our mother you can blame me for that too
There scene's better than Jaime and Cersei scene at the end of the episode even though that was a bigger payoff like Jaime is
finally leaving Cersei
but number six
littlefinger's and
Sansa's last big scene together where he starts to imply that arya wants to kill her she's worried about what jon Snow's doing with this
Alliance with Daenerys
And you have this sort of work this moment in reverse from what ends up happening to littlefinger later when he gets killed by Arya
Like at what point did Sansa learned about what he did in King's landing because we didn't see that
conversation with Bran so what I think the idea is is that as of last week's episode when Arya is still going at it with
Sansa they're still being genuine in that moment
But arya has already had that conversation with Sansa earlier in the episode where she basically tells her that's not me
I don't want to be the lady of a castle like you did so I think that littlefinger's
critical mistake is when he
suggests that arya wants to be the lady of winterfell and Sansa had just gotten done going back and forth with Arya about how she
Didn't want any of that, so it's a little hard to read Sophie Turner's face here, but you see her paws a little bit
I'm guessing that after this happened then she went to talk to Arya and bran
Then they learned about all the stuff that happened in King's landing him betraying ned stark him being responsible for Jon Arryn
Precipitating everything that led to the war of the five kings although he wasn't completely responsible
He was definitely behind most of it
But there had to have been a scene where bran
Explained all that to them because Sansa only knew about a little bit of it
She knew about littlefinger killing Lysa, but all the stuff back during season one the king's landing ned stark stuff
she and
Arya wouldn't have known about any of that unless bran told them and I'm assuming that because bran was sitting in the room during the
Scene they had just gotten done talking to him but number 5 that amazing
Theon seen with Jon where it's basically like a version of brienne and jaime where Jon's good qualities have started to rub off on
Theon and now he's inspired to go rescue his sister
But he's at war within himself and Jon gives in the big speech about how you don't have to pick one or the other stark
or Greyjoy
You don't have to betray one to honor the other
He has that great fight club scene where he takes down the person who fished him out of the water
He's the stepping stone that theon needs to inspire the others and it's really that small band there to go to save Yara
So that's gonna be a big season 8 thing the other important thing in that John conversation, too
Is is sort of the hat tip for?
Targaryen stuff happening in the future like how is Jon Snow gonna deal with the reveal that he's half targaryen
And it sounds like incest bomb aside
He'll actually be able to deal with it
Relatively well because that's basically what he tells Theon is that you don't have to pick one family or the other
So we got a big battle between your on and theon happening in season eight, but number four arya executes littlefinger
So it's such a big character death
But I'm just so happy that they're moving past this garbage Sansa Arya storyline like I said earlier in the video
There's a certain point at which they figured out
What littlefinger was doing after a bran explained all of his treachery so I feel like that all happened off screen
And we weren't meant to see it just so we could get this surprise here whether or not you were surprised
I mean, I really felt like littlefinger was Gonna die this season
So when she turned her head and little fingers like what are you talking about?
I have no idea about this treachery you speak of there was a moment of surprise on my face
But I was like okay. This is how it happens
This is the moment
But honestly they've kind of been dumping on the littlefinger character for the last couple of seasons in favor of Sansa's storyline and her
Development and there was a lot of stuff that got shoehorned into this false
Conflict between her and arya that I'm just glad that the storyline is over and we don't have to deal with it again
So it was a big moment
I love how arya executed him
But I'm not happy in the way the writers got there even though we were headed in this direction
eventually
But number three samwell rolls up with gilly and we learned that he actually paid attention
When she was talking about the maester who recorded all of his craps so you brush through it really quickly
I was surprised by how quickly they rolled into that flashback you get the rhaegar lynna marriage
And I actually laughed a little bit when bran was like his name is actually sand
Because bastards in dorne are named sand and I almost wanted to shout out
No, he'd actually be a waters because he was born to a targaryen and his father would have had naming rights
It's not just where you're born
It's actually who you're born to
But you can argue about what his true bastard name would be because they revealed that his real name is aegon targaryen
So there's a really cool reveal really happened
They finally paid that off
but it also raises some interesting questions too because there's the fake aegon of the books and if George R Martin
Explained that John's true. Name is aegon then
It's only more confirmation that fake aegon is actually a blackfyre not a true targaryen
but because fake aegon is
Pretending to be the baby of Rhaegar and Elia martell it reminds you that rhaegar already had a son with Elia named aegon
So why then is rhaegar obsessed with having a new baby the fulfillment of the prophecy in naming it aegon again?
Did he just change the name of his last baby like he just has a bunch of babies named aegon now
So you guys can let me know do you think that his name will also be aegon in the books?
Because even though they changed minor things and bump up characters storylines big reveals like that like R. Plus L equals J
Feels like it would have to be relatively true to the book reveal but bran is amazingly lucid in this scene
And I love when Samwell rolls up and he explains how he's the three-eyed Raven and he gives him the same look that Sansa gave
Him I don't know what that means that's like the default reaction to three-eyed Raven
I have absolutely no idea what that means
But as they make the big reveal about the marriage his true name you get to boatsex
And as you know fun as this big payoff is like, okay?
This incest bomb is gonna blow up in season eight. It's gonna be so fun to see what they do with it
You see Tyrians face off in the hallway looking very concerned like ooh this might not end well like he's not excited for them
He actually looks worried like this might end badly
But if you remember earlier in the episode they actually tipped the hat to future daenerys, baby
Possibilities because as she's explaining the end of the targaryen family in the dragon pit
She reminds us like she literally says I will never have more children
I actually just posted a video about the Mirri Maz Duur prophecy
She shouts her out to the woman who murdered my child and my husband told me that I would never have children again
So we'll add a link for that at the end of this
but it's all just clues pointing to the
Possibility that daenerys could become pregnant at some point in season 8 and I don't know that we'd ever see the baby be born
On the show because there's not that much time but we'll see I'll talk more about that on my season 8 predictions video and then
Of course number one big night king reveal army of the dead bringing the wall down r.i.p
The wall pretty much the only big action set piece in the episode
But we knew it would have to happen eventually the army of the dead was eventually gonna make it south of the wall
But we got a couple explainers, so we know what's up with Viserion now
There was a night king end game video that I did for
Season 8 stuff like what is the actual final battle it gonna look like how they gonna defeat him how they gonna defeat
Viserion there were a lot of mechanical questions about Viserion like how does he work? What are his powers?
Is he still able to fly so per this scene here?
It looks like he has all the same abilities that he had when he was still alive
Is that now he breathes blew fire and for those are you wondering whether or not that makes sense?
I think the idea is that the knight King's magic is just preventing him from
Exploding into flame because flame kills white's now that he's an undead white if he breathed flamed. He should then also burst into flames
But it'll be a lot of fun to see him flying around during season eight so now he's super fast and I love the shot
Of then just slowly casually walking down through the wall like they just roll up and stop
They're not in a rush at all
But you see this giant
Black winter storm behind that so when they say the long night it literally looks like night because the sky is so thick with snow
And storm that it blots out all light
So then you go back to the shot of Cersei's floor map with winter falling on the kingdom
And there's just a lot of nice visual metaphors in the episode
So I was much happier with this than almost any other episode this season
But let me know in the comments favorite episode this season in Favorite moment in this episode, but like I said
What's Gonna happen next is I'll do my season 8 predictions video
Then I'll do my q&A video you just leave all your bonus video requests
There's a bunch of mythology things that we can talk about now
There haven't been any season 8 leaks so we can freely talk about anything
We want to now that the season is over, so it's all fair game
Congratulations the latest Giveaway winner Andrew Chamberlain
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
You can click here to learn all about the Daenerys prophecy Mirri Maz Duur
And why she might have another child and you can click here to learn all about rhaegar Lyanna Back story?
Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight